If the AST and ALT in blood test shows 21 to 22, does that mean the liver is in good shape, is there not congestion?
Can we rely on these tests?
Well, no, just like any test, it's just one test.
So a person can have fatty liver disease that have normal AST, ALT and alcohol and phosphatase.
That doesn't mean you don't have fatty liver disease.
The person can have liver cancer and have normal liver function markers.
So it's amazing how well your body is trying to live and survive and cope with all sorts of problems.
And your blood work that shows on a CBC and a complete metabolic panel is not a perfect test for total liver function.
So AST and ALT will be elevated if you have inflammatory acute or chronic inflammatory liver, maybe from acute toxicity.
I had one person years ago that I don't remember what they were taking some drug, but they had super high AST and ALT numbers.
For a short period of time, went off that drug and everything came back in balance relatively quickly.
But this is why people die in Tylenol poisoning.
You think, oh, Tylenol is a safe drug or Advil, and these non-steroidal anti-inflammatories are safe drugs to take.
Anything, I guess, is safe. It's all about dosage and it's exceeding that person's dosage.
What is the LD, the lethal dosage for that person?
Everybody's a little bit different. So if you do anything that could cause hyperinflammatory response in any organ that organ could shut down,
that's why people die of non-steroidal drugs, because their liver just basically shuts down and they have acute liver failure, they die.
So I mean, last statistic I saw that in the United States, it's a load over 15,000 people die of Tylenol and Advil poisoning every year.
So that's just them using it over the code.
So these are good markers to look at, but like any lamb, it's just one marker.
So it doesn't tell us none of the liver markers tell us how well the phase one, phase two, phase three detoxification pathways are functioning.
You can still have congestion of the liver and it's not functioning.
You know, your rate of toxicification could still be exceeding your rate of detoxification.
So there's no way to totally measure that. That's why we look at your genetics and look at those pathways to say,
you are going to be a slow detoxer from many people know that already. I can't take this strong because I feel sick if I take even Tylenol, I feel sick.
What tells you probably got very slow phase one phase two pathways is probably should not you're going to need to be hyper vigilant about taking those things because you don't get rid of them very fast.